next question next question throughout
modern history the musicians have often
been the voice of the common man's
descent
against the ruling class the man stick
it to the man
what is the current musical movement
that is dissenting
against the official narrative
look yeah this is accurate right there's
there's always well there's it seems
gonna be a rebellious streak that comes
from music that's trying to push the
envelope at one point it was rock and
roll
right then it moved into sort of
like psychedelic rock and then that sort
of heavy metal punk
hardcore
you had rap come in
um
now as these things as these musical
genres get more popular they actually
get taken over by
the man
right i mean you end up with uh
with uh pop punk and hair metal that's
what happens
right
boy bands yeah boy bands bruh boy benz
is the ultimate
takeover by the man yeah
ultimate if you ever look into how those
are made yeah no they are they're
they're manufactured um
are there still
yeah there's still bands that are out
there that you just have to go a little
bit deeper i think you just have to go a
little bit deeper in fact right now the
accessibility to
the rebels is very
very it's very accessible like when i
was a kid
it was funny when i was i loved music
and when i was a kid i didn't have that
many records because it was hard to find
good records and when you did find them
they cost 18 which was a ton of money
nowadays you just type into youtube uh
you know
viking folk medal and you got it there
it is you know it could ask you anything
right
you can you know desert stone or rock
you put it in there there it is you can
get you can go deep you can listen you
could listen to stoner rock for the rest
of your life and not even listen to it
all right that's just the way it is so
all that music's out there um
all there's all kinds of just
radical
kind of music that's out there there's
this band i've been listening to called
hyalung
it means healing
in
norwegian or some
and
they they're up there on stage there's
like
14 people in the band they're playing
all these different
instruments and when i say different i
mean different they're playing like
bones
they got like they got like femurs
and goat skin drums and
you know horse heads that they're
banging on
and there's a guy that kind of sings in
a sort of death metal-ish type thing and
there's some chanting going on and then
there's this woman named maria franz
who's got some pipes on her and she's
wearing this weird antler outfit with
antlers on her heads so look man it is
out there
well it's out there the stuff is out
there
and i look i
i don't even think you need i don't
think you need me to point you to it i
think you go and just start exploring
what's out there
and you'll find it
yeah i think you're right about that
here's the challenge though where with
unlimited accessibility comes unlimited
choice and unless it's like like you
ever go to a restaurant and the menu is
like five pages long and you're like
okay you find you you're good because a
lot of things sound good and not to
mention it's like man you come across
the thing that looks good hey i'm just
gonna get that bro i'm not gonna read
this whole menu and then years later you
go there all the time and someone's like
hey everybody in this restaurant you say
yeah i go there all the time i get this
and they say oh okay well i get this
thing i didn't even know they had that i
don't try the other stuff yeah see and
that's kind of part of my point right
there
yeah yep you're right
you're right and i'll tell you i mostly
i do mostly listen to the same music
that i've been listening to my whole
life which is kind of lame right because
shouldn't i be
doing well i guess i i i do get out
there here's what i thought here's where
i thought you were going with this
when i was a kid
the first thing i wanted to know when i
met someone was what kind of music do
you listen to
because to me that kind of told the
story of who that person was whereas
nowadays everyone wants everyone's
answer everything yeah and guess what
it's not even it's not that it's not
true people really do listen everything
because you know why an album doesn't
cost 18
an album is free basically so everyone
goes yeah i listen to that i listen to
this other thing i think it's
it's not bad it's not good it's just
different yeah people are have more
broad musical taste now than they did
when i was a kid you didn't have you
didn't get that you didn't get to be you
weren't able to do that you just
listened to the
seven albums that you had that's it
you get stuck and that's not to mention
that the albums back in your day uh were
they're real more they're more distinct
you know where if it's like hey you like
rocco here's a rock album oh you like
rap here's a rap album you like you know
country whether you know here's
now bro there's so much fusion yeah and
new things it's like man you got
freaking what's his name
i don't know their names but there's
like a country view the old town road
and the rapper and the country guy and
they're doing a song and it's a massive
hit you know it's like okay like it it's
like oh i listen to country okay here's
some country oh wait that's not country
that's rap oh well it's both
saying so it's like okay so you asking
uh oh what kind of music do you listen
to kind of thing it's like okay that's
less of a thing that doesn't make it
doesn't make it happen anymore hey you
ever listen to like yo you do you listen
to like rap because you listen to
essentially one kind of music even now
right or just well no i don't think
that's necessarily true because i listen
to metal the metal right i'll listen to
black sabbath sure hell yeah i'll listen
to ozzy osbourne on the way over here
there you go uh so i do listen to that
but i do yeah i listen to hardcore for
sure that's sort of the main staple of
the whole diet
uh but i listen to rock and roll too
what what are you asking what's your
favorite rap song or hip hop song like
and i'm not even necessarily right now
i'm saying ever like before one that
you'd put on
if any
i don't know
maybe ll cool j
maybe
i mean nwa's first album
i mean come on that's just
undeniable yeah
yeah
yeah a lot of times tupac even if people
don't listen to rap they listen to tupac
because he kind of like
he's a lot more poetic yeah you know and
maybe they appreciate that even if
they're not necessarily into the style
or whatever
it's interesting
yeah but it yes so back to the selection
and accessibility when i was a kid run
dmc was like issued to you oh yeah randy
of sierra
from the east coast yeah you know and
from outside new york and run dmc was
you would you say und they were
undeniable yeah it was run dmc it was a
whole
there was a just
there was a movie with run dmc and it
was the thing is run dmc nwa though they
had riff driven rock and roll
uh
right sampling yeah and so
of course you're listening to it when
you're a kid like me you're like oh well
you recognize that that's a guitar riff
yeah remember run dmc did a fusion uh
song with um what's his name aerosmith
yeah remember that yeah walk this way
yeah that was your jam right there no
actually i was if you could see the look
on my face
i was already kind of come on you know
why you know why why
because when that happened it was like
the man was taking it oh yeah it was too
so it wasn't poppy
it was the man was taking it away it
wasn't uh i i'm one of those people like
a music a little bit of a music snob
yeah i gotta gather that for me a little
bit this is oh you know we like to stay
old school yeah like you're the kind of
guy who
and what we were talking about earlier
off offline
how like you'll be like no this
underground artist heart metal or
whoever whatever you listen to uh this
artist
way less well-known is way better than
this mainstream artist well a lot of
times they actually are oh what do you
mean actually i see that and that proves
my point right there yeah you know uh
under what circumstances what do you
mean better albums okay no i'm gonna
throw something back
at you
because you've been using this example
with me lately right
what's better
uh this our this artist this music
artist that sold this many records or
this one you're always like well you
know the guy sold more therefore they're
better no
okay what's better steak or mcdonald's
sells more right yeah it's true so
yes first off i would never say that i
would never say oh this guy sells more
so he's better because that's why that's
why i always say like if you notice i'll
be like depends on what you mean by x y
z
the word better is always or very often
time one of those things that i'll say
that about because then that was my
whole argument when i had that this that
quote-unquote debate with my friend tim
our friend tim where he's saying this
underground rapper is better than lil
wayne or whoever i was like but what do
you mean by better
because i could make the argument i'm
not making it but i could that little
wayne is better because of and then i
start naming this criteria album sales
uh awards you know by the people you
know how many awards and album sales
does your underground guy have and then
it's way less so it's like cool i'm not
saying he's worse or better i'm just
saying you got to measure it by a
certain by or you have to measure it a
certain way you see what i'm saying cool
now that i measure things by what i
think is better what you think is better
oh yeah i'm right it's oh yeah and
you're right okay and what the thing is
though you do have a point though and so
tim he started saying well if you listen
to the lyrics they're more complex and
all this and i was like now you're on to
something because just like if like if
you you have the mcdonald's or or fat
we'll say fast food comparison to like a
i don't know steak or whatever and
you're like well mcdonald's sells
trillions of hamburgers so they're
better by that metric
cool if you're if you're measuring
quote-unquote better by that standard
yes but there is a lot to be said for
certain elements that are less tangible
check not intangible less tangible it's
insane and i think we all can sense that
a lot of the time
that's the current conundrum that's what
i think next question